weil es hier wohl nachts relativ
gefährlich ist vor allem auf dieser
straße da und man einfach ausgeraubt
werden kann und die wahrscheinlichkeit
dazu ist gar nicht mal geringer also das
echt krass deswegen fahren wir jetzt mit
kuba über schon wieder an mustern
[Musik]
diese zahl wird und damit etwas gedacht
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
blog hier warte ist immer so laut
deutsche draußen ist es noch dunkel wir
haben gerade halb sieben und für mich
geht es heute nach los angeles das ist
einfach mein allererstes mal in amerika
überhaupt bei aller erstes mal ziemlich
weit weg von zu hause und ich habe super
bock jetzt geht es erstmal nach
düsseldorf zum flughafen von düsseldorf
geht es nach dublin und von dublin dann
irgendwann hoffentlich nach los angeles
nehmen euch mit
und ich wünsche euch viel spaß wird
sagen was ist denn da los da brennt oder
was ich bin es ankommt in düsseldorf am
flughafen und jetzt warte ich auf nach
dublin wie zucker brötchen bestellt bis
ich gemerkt hat dass er musik
red
[Musik]
so leute angekommen in dublin
so leute ich bin jetzt hier im
offiziellen us abteil keine ahnung wie
man slam auf jeden fall war das gerade
alles sehr strengen der typ hat mich
gefragt ob ich irgendwie bananen
mitnehmen oder so was ich da genau mache
habe ich so gar nicht gedacht aber gut
sieht es eigentlich scheiße aus mit
diesem ring wird sich in zeiten die
nicht darin zu 426 und angeflogen
[Musik]
jetzt ist
leute wir haben nächsten morgen und wir
sind schon angekommen hier nelly und das
ist unsere aussicht aus unserem hotel
werden wir gestern so den vorhin
aufgemacht dachten vor mal gucken was
sie für eine aussicht haben und man kann
einfach dieser in ruh wir sind hier im
hilton hotel direkt am flughafen und es
war gestern so ein wie nennt man das
aber es war gestern so ein horror bis
wir in diesem zimmer waren deswegen habe
ich auch gar nichts mehr aufgenommen und
zwar konnten wir einfach nirgendwo
geldabheben keine von unseren
kreditkarten und auch von irgendwelchen
bankkarten hat funktioniert und dann
könnten wir zum glück leute hier die uns
erst mal geld geliehen haben sonst
werden wir einfach auf der straße
gelandet also wir sind hier um 19 uhr
gelandet und waren jetzt um 24 uhr in
diesem zimmer
das war echt krass vor allem ich habe
echt nicht viel geschlafen jetzt geht's
erst mal los ich nehme euch mit wir
machen heute im block und mal schauen wo
es hingeht sagen viel spaß
let's go
[Musik]
sollte was geht wir sind jetzt hier
schon am venice santa monica pier wir
waren gerade beim mac ist das krass ist
da ist alles einfach das ist eine
mittlere oder so und das sind 0,7 5
milliliter du kannst du aufhören
wieduwilt irgendwie hab ich gar kein
schlechtes gewissen mich ungesund zu
ernähren weil das macht jeder so
zumindest alle menschen gerade in diesem
mix waren und was man auch sagen muss
mein heiß geliebter muss dann ist total
normal
ich habe bestimmt schon 20 mustangs
gesehen und wir sind gerade mal 20
minuten hier also das ist echt heftig so
leute wir sind jetzt hier an diesem
strand den man eigentlich aus jedem film
kennen bei diesem freizeitpark dahinter
ist auf jeden fall cool haben gerade ein
paar coole fotos gemacht wollte mir auf
jeden fall auf instagram daher sich alex
lee und jack die fotos ab jetzt gleich
geht es noch weiter wohin weiß ich nicht
werden jetzt durch abgeholt von drei
freund von uns die hier auch wohnen
gerade und ich bin jetzt wirklich schon
begeistert und wir sehen auch so sehen
werden
[Musik]
so leute wir sind jetzt hier in
chinatown und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
auch jetzt auf jeden fall schon eine
geile aussicht und hier kann man jetzt
schon sehen das sieht aus wie ganz so
ein bisschen wie china
[Musik]
also wir gehen jetzt erst mal runter was
essen und dann fahren wir gleich noch zu
diesen kanälen von gta aber das ist uns
das auto was ist das noch mal ein auto
hier wird einfach jeder knallerbsen auf
dem boden und es nennt
also ich muss sagen ich bin wirklich
fasziniert ich habe mir das nicht so
krass vorgestellt aber es sieht wirklich
genau so aus wie man das auch so filmen
kennen keine ahnung wahrscheinlich waren
ja viele von euch auch schon mal hier
aber ich kann es wirklich jedem nur
empfehlen also ich mal hinzufahren ist
wirklich so auf den ersten eindruck und
eine ganz andere welt
daumen nach oben könnt ihr auch beim
video machen übrigens noch mal verliehen
und der nächste muss dann dort das
wasser erst mal hier mit china town
schmidt ja auch eigentlich in amerika
und in china tragen diesem restaurant
gegenüber also ponys die schon da
gegessen haben davon kann ich genau 2
[Musik]
das ist so krass egal wo man ist über
ist irgendwie geil los also es ist sehr
verdreckt das sieht man auch da hinten
wieder
aber irgendwie finde ich situation tun
ich weiß nicht ob man das jetzt durch
die kamera so fühlen kann aber
vielleicht versteht ihr was ich meine
auf jeden fall wollten wir gerade in die
kanäle runter da ist alles irgendwie zu
und wir müssen jetzt die tage noch mal
schauen ob wir da noch irgendwie hin
kommen wir sind und drüber gefahren ich
habe das jetzt leider nicht gefilmt und
so ist aber noch ein paar nette fotos
gemacht auf jeden fall instagram alex
wie also von außen sieht das auto bloß
von innen nicht mal wie viel müll hier
liegt alles leute rein die wohn welche
dinge
wer hier wohnen menschen die wollen
jetzt menschen drin kosten
[Musik]
70 werke ich hier auf meinen sechsten
stock dass dieses alter
gebt euch den ausblick war das ist ja
echt ein recht hoch in deutschland
müsste man das wieder getan
deutlich war gerade zum ersten mal in
meinem leben bei innen out burger hier
hinter mir und der burger war heftig gut
und er hat sogar nur sieben dollar
gekostet also das echt krass dass
mcdonald's das nicht so gut hinbekommt
und eigentlich sogar noch teurer ist
also kann ich jedem von euch nur
empfehlen wenn ihr hier seid geht auf
jeden fall zwei in out burger oder zu
viel geist weil das gibt es nicht so
viel in deutschland in den outdoor gibt
es gar nicht gibt es glaube ich in essen
frankfurt aber das ist wirklich ein
richtig richtig guter bürger und ist
auch gar nicht so teuer
wasser war auf jeden fall auch dass
unser hotel ist irgendwo dahinten also
ungefähr einen kilometer von
ungefähr einen kilometer von hier das
sollte man aber besser nicht laufen wenn
es dunkel ist weil es hier wohl nachts
relativ gefährlich ist vor allem auf
dieser straße da und man einfach
ausgeraubt werden kann und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dazu ist gar nicht
mal gering also das echt krass deswegen
fahren wir jetzt mit kuba über schon
wieder muss
das ist übrigens die hotellobby
so leute um das andere zimmer nicht
aufgeräumt
ich glaube ich mache das weil ich sehr
aufgeräumt war
sie dachte das wird morgen denn der
werker liegen sollte auf jeden fall ist
dass wir unser zimmer
ich weiß nicht vielleicht nehme ich das
morgen war noch einmal auf wenn es jetzt
blöd aussieht vom richter kein kran auf
jeden fall war es ein tag oder unser
erster tag hier in einer bar megacool
lass doch mal unter wenn sie gefallen
hat wir sehen uns keine ahnung und
wieder und ja boni nicht vergessen
instagram ab da kommt coole fotos ich
schlafe jetzt leute was geht aber ich
hoffe ihr seht mich oder waren deutsche
waren deutsche wir sind sie gerade noch
hochgefahren gebt euch mal diesen
ausbringen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so läutet jetzt ist es dunkel geworden
hiermit beendet jetzt ein zweites mal
das video was ich noch sagen wollt ihr
könnt gerne in die kommentare schreiben
was ihr für videos sehen wollt hier aus
alle irgendwie bürger leben oder sonst
was da gibt es ja auf jeden fall mehr
als genug
und das ist ja auch noch angenehm waren
das macht aufpasst und ich habe gerade
eine fette time maps gemacht die ist
richtig cool geworden
schon wieder schon wieder ein mustern ja
damit endlich jetzt das video sei das
auto